so this is a short list of what we might
have missed out on the godzilla versus
gong super bowl trailer
including the scenes from the japanese
trailer that was also released recently
first of all let us just say kudos to
hbo max for
making it rain for throwing away a lot
of money for every second that's worth
it
to be honest yeah you guys should know
that for a 30 second trailer slot in the
super bowl
the price tag is 5.5 million dollars so
with that in mind let's see the trailer
scenes and what we might have missed out
let's make this short and sweet shall we
after all it's a 30 second trailer
alright first we see godzilla climbing
on top of an aircraft carrier yeah seen
it
okay same kong punch no difference in
reaction
yes the same scene where everyone in the
ship is shocked at godzilla's arrival
just to remind you again they were not
planning on the two times meeting
especially at c okay uh make a godzilla
destroys buildings check it's really
amazing to think that the strength of
the alloy
on the exterior of the mecca to still
shine bright like a diamond after all
that
okay yada yada same old scenes
oh wait a minute the tv screen that we
did not dissect earlier
so it was also in the earlier trailer it
says that godzilla attacked pensacola in
florida
then we have a close-up shot of that yi
ass haircut of ren serizawa to be honest
he doesn't look all that scheming and
sinister at all
if he was to be the brains behind mecha
godzilla he kind of looks like a bts
member with a moustache
all in all i hope he does well though
being the one behind the mechanized
titan and also the son of serizawa does
carry a lot of burden and expectations
next we have a new one a very cool short
scene of godzilla's atomic breath
a close-up shot of the nuclear lizard
going all out destroying stuff
it seems to be of the same scene where
he attacked a military base
again i would press on this godzilla is
actually in search of something
and as it was said in the trailer
something is provoking him
so there is in fact a method to his
madness but this scene is just god
damn the blue tone of the atomic breath
and the dorsal plates glowing is just
awesome
a lot of people say this is mecca
godzilla
and in the words of another youtuber
called wars 2
it's not deal with it okay so what do we
have here
is madison in a concentration camp why
is she in an asian concentration camp
was she old enough to drive the van why
would anyone care though monsters are
out attacking the world
and madison is thrown inside a cage for
a dui i suppose
along with the other children really
hope she gets out
okay next oh this is the one we have
been waiting for to review
godzilla [ __ ] slaps le monkey in the
first scene
kong gives godzilla a superman punch
godzilla the heavyweight
now retaliates with a big show slap yes
these are wwe references and to be fair
godzilla vs kong
would be a heavyweight championship
match no disqualification
and now let's go take a look at the
japanese trailer scenes okay same stuff
same old fighty story stuff ah
this is the one here godzilla dives to
avoid powerful missiles
if you're wondering why godzilla needs
to avoid missiles it's safe to say that
although the titan is near invulnerable
to such weapons
bigger explosions do in fact have a
small effect especially if they are
aimed at the dorsal plates
so this scene here reminds us of the
fact that godzilla is a primarily
oceanic titan and his realm is the sea
so that's about it oh wait one more
thing
if you closely check the scene here
where gong was fighting with godzilla
you would see that godzilla is actually
heavily injured in the fight against
kong
whether it's the scars from the battle
axe is yet unknown
but it has a high probability so with
that we come to the end of the video
do like for support smash that subscribe
button to be a part of the mind cue
family
and slap slap slap that notification
bell for regular updates
till the next one take care fam